what's for lunch H I got us um some
sandwiches sandwiches yep my fa guess
what I got you though what turkey
awesome got
veggy
Vern Vern come in all no I'm good come
on it's shallow H it doesn't look that
shallow don't be a
[__] all right give me a
sec burn burn oh my God
[Music]
burn wow ver you really outed yourself
you haven't seen nothing yet
oh my God my favorite
[Music]
song
hey you okay I'm sorry I'm
sorry it's
nice I think we're good
right
[Music]
okay oh no I
got
[Music]
[Applause]
uh Veron are you sure you can drive yeah
I got this we're on a
date
okay
[Music]
God you know where you're going oh
[__] did I hit something burn
burn y all
right let's go
[Music]
home
yeah
[Music]
come on Steelers baby let's
go
a